dea
今から日本語のレッスンを行います
日本ではいわゆる省略語が日常的に使われている
たとえば女子高生のことを jk と言ったり空気が読めない人のことを koi と
呼んだりするなど専門家によるとこの省略語の利用頻度は増えているそうだ
個人的にぼ
子はこの省略語が好きじゃないけど日本語の一部であるって言うことは否定できないの
で今日は省略号いくつか紹介したいと思う
具体的に言うと未来の日本でできそうな省略語
一番
東京五輪の準備と観光客でこれまでにない混雑が起こってしまうと予想して ojt
オリンピック渋滞2番ハーフの人がどんどん増えて日本人よりハーフとそうでない
ハーフのグループがはっきりできてしまうと予想して
sgh mgh 寿司付きハーフマック月合う
3番いつかハーフでもなく日本で生まれ育った純粋な外国人はミス日本になると予想し
て
mis まさかの優勝4番優勝者がブラジル人であるため
カーニバルブームが起こると予想して sbd 3ばボディ
ダイエット5番 tpp のせいで汚い牛肉がどんどん増えて食中毒で死ぬ人が激増
すると予想して
in bs モスバーガーし6番このままアイドルブームが拡大し続け
ど田舎にでもアイドルグループができてしまうと予想して
ksm フォーティーエイト上嶋フォーティーエイト
7番
いつしかアイドルバーブルがパンクし日本全国がその音楽一線に効かなくなると予想し
て
4 t 8 h s 4 d 7 td fk
フォーティーエイト反対する4 t 7都道府県8番多くなった外国人に
今日受けて日本人もいろんな面でゆるくなると予想して
jpc 10分遅刻9番書士高齢カーで税金がさらに上がって貯金が出来なくて困る人
が増えると予想して
1型5 h 1キッチンファイル1十分他の単語も省略してるからこれも省略して良い
んじゃねえと思う人が出るという
そして kfc 健太ケンタッキー
11番外資系が最新技術をどんどん取り入れていくのを見て多くの人が自分の会社の頭
の硬さに気付くと予想して
mgk 無駄な業務会12番最新技術を入れすぎてしまった外資系が混乱して潰れて
いくの
見て日本企業が降る1週間を極めると予想して
in my f メールよりファックス13番そもそも変な外来語と省略語を使う必要
がなく純粋な国語を離した方が分かりやすいとみんなが気づくと予想して日本語
日本語
ni